so the podcast idea got that that's done
but how am I gonna record the
conversations how am I gonna distribute
it to the world how people gonna listen
to my podcasts water share of you guys
next was well how am I actually gonna
record these conversations under me have
in how am I gonna distribute the podcast
episodes etc now this may sound like one
of the hardest parts but it's actually
one of the easiest and that's simply
down to a brilliant brilliant piece of
software called anchor if you haven't
heard about it give it a googol because
it's brilliant
so let me explain how I'm gonna be using
it to create my podcast basically so I'm
gonna be having conversations with
guests so how do I invite these people
to use this app or how do I get a
conversation recorded so it's really
really easy so firstly no one's gonna
have to sign up for this app so it's not
sort of lengthy on the other person's
end and but I'll go into the app and it
will go you basically click on a
function which says invite friends so
you can invite people who are already on
the actual app or you can invite your
contacts so when you invite someone from
your contacts it will generate sort of a
link which you'll be able to send
through whatsapp messenger or whatever
when they get that link they'll
basically then be told right you have to
download the app they'll do that takes
two seconds but they won't have to sign
up and then before they get even into
the conversation it will say basically
you're about to enter a conversation on
anchor which is going to be recorded
is this okay and then they click yes and
then they're in the conversation now a
really really cool part to this is that
when they get into the conversation
because you're actually having a
conversation in the actual app itself
this sound quality is brilliant so I
actually haven't had to buy or I'm going
to I'm not going to buy any sort of
fancy microphone gear or anything like
that
literally gonna be using my Apple
headphones and the sound quality are
I've tried it is literally its class
it's perfect and that's just because
you're basically having the conversation
it's recorded both both of you through
the app so that's the first thing and
that's how the conversation has actually
been recorded so secondly how am I going
to distribute the actual episodes and
the recordings so again this is really
really easy all done in the app so you
can actually create the actual episode
in the app itself so you basically
create segments so I all like record the
introduction and put that in the segment
as intro and then you can use some
sounds that they have to sort of
transition it into the next part of the
podcast and then you add the sort of
interview with a guest and then that's
basically the actual episode sort of
built in the app and then you basically
publish that as a full episodes that
then becomes just one whole piece and
then to distribute it you literally
click one but at bottom it says publish
everywhere and with that button it's
then distributed to five different
platforms instantly you'll get different
links which you can share it with your
different socials to get people linking
on the Apple podcasts or just listening
through anchor fm etc so honestly using
that anchor software to start a podcast
is super super easy so what I'm gonna be
using and it doesn't mean that you're
gonna have to buy a fancy piece of gear
for microphone or that sort of stuff
you're not gonna worry about how you're
gonna get onto the different platforms
it's all done through one centralized
app and that's called anchor so I will
leave a link on this video for those of
you that are lazy and don't know Google
it so I put a link on there you can
click that check it out
but that's what I'm gonna be using the
for for my podcast and then the creation
on my podcast so there we go
[Music]